I now want to emphasize
an important point.
Conditional probabilities are
just the same as ordinary
probabilities applied to
a different situation.
They do not taste or smell or
behave any differently than
ordinary probabilities.
What do I mean by that?
I mean that they satisfy the
usual probability axioms.
For example, ordinary
probabilities must also be
non-negative.
Is this true for conditional
probabilities?
Of course it is true, because
conditional probabilities are
defined as a ratio of
two probabilities.
Probabilities are
non-negative.
So the ratio will also be
non-negative, of course as
long as it is well-defined.
And here we need to remember
that we only talk about
conditional probabilities when
we condition on an event that
itself has positive
probability.
How about another axiom?
What is the probability of
the entire sample space,
given the event B?
Let's check it out.
By definition, the conditional
probability is the probability
of the intersection of the two
events involved divided by the
probability of the conditioning
event.
Now, what is the intersection
of omega with B?
B is a subset of omega.
So when we intersect
the two sets, we're
left just with B itself.
So the numerator becomes the
probability of B. We're
dividing by the probability
of B, and so the
answer is equal to 1.
So indeed, the sample space
has unit probability, even
under the conditional model.
Now, remember that when we
condition on an event B, we
could still work with the
original sample space.
However, possible outcomes that
do not belong to B are
considered impossible, so we
might as well think of B
itself as being our
sample space.
If we proceed like that and
think now of B as being our
new sample space, what is the
probability of this new sample
space in the conditional
model?
Let's apply the definition
once more.
It's the probability of the
intersection of the two events
involved, B intersection B,
divided by the probability of
the conditioning event.
What is the numerator?
The intersection of B with
itself is just B, so the
numerator is the probability
of B. We're dividing by the
probability of B. So the
answer is, again, 1.
Finally, we need to check
the additivity axiom.
Recall what the additivity
axiom says.
If we have two events, two
subsets of the sample space
that are disjoint, then the
probability of their union is
equal to the sum of their
individual probabilities.
Is this going to be the case
if we now condition on a
certain event?
What we want to prove is the
following statement.
If we take two events that are
disjoint, they have empty
intersection, then the
probability of the union is
the sum of their individual
probabilities, but where now
the probabilities that we're
employing are the conditional
probabilities, given the event
B. So let us verify whether
this relation, this fact
is correct or not.
Let us take this quantity
and use the
definition to write it out.
By definition, this conditional
probability is the
probability of the intersection
of the first
event of interest, the one that
appears on this side of
the conditioning, intersection
with the event on which we are
conditioning.
And then we divide by the
probability of the
conditioning event, B. Now,
let's look at this quantity,
what is it?
We're taking the union of A with
C, and then intersect it
with B. This union consists
of these two pieces.
When we intersect with
B, what is left is
these two pieces here.
So A union C intersected with B
is the union of two pieces.
One piece is A intersection
B, this piece here.
And another piece, which is C
intersection B, this is the
second piece here.
So here we basically used a
set theoretic identity.
And now we divide by the
same [denominator]
as before.
And now let us continue.
Here's an interesting
observation.
The events A and
C are disjoint.
The piece of A that also belongs
in B, therefore, is
disjoint from the piece of
C that also belongs to B.
Therefore, this set here and
that set here are disjoint.
Since they are disjoint, the
probability of their union has
to be equal to the sum
of their individual
probabilities.
So here we're using the
additivity axiom on the
original probabilities to break
this probability up into
two pieces.
And now we observe that here
we have the ratio of an
intersection by the probability
of B. This is just
the conditional probability of A
given B using the definition
of conditional probabilities.
And the second part is the
conditional probability of C
given B, where, again, we're
using the definition of
conditional probabilities.
So we have indeed checked that
this additivity property is
true for the case of conditional
probabilities when
we consider two disjoint
events.
Now, we could repeat the same
derivation and verify that it
is also true for the case of a
disjoint union, of finitely
many events, or even
for countably
many disjoint events.
So we do have finite and
countable additivity.
We're not proving it, but the
argument is exactly the same
as for the case of two events.
So conditional probabilities do
satisfy all of the standard
axioms of probability theory.
So conditional probabilities
are just like ordinary
probabilities.
This actually has a very
important implication.
Since conditional probabilities
satisfy all of
the probability axioms, any
formula or theorem that we
ever derive for ordinary
probabilities will remain true
for conditional probabilities
as well.